Transcription: Chloé Nicolin
Relecteur: eric vautier
La route vers les étoiles ne laisse-t-elle
vraiment rien au hasard ?
Si vous avez en tête les images
d’un décollage d’Ariane 5,
ou celles d’une sortie extravéhiculaire
effectuée depuis la Station spatiale
internationale par Thomas Pesquet,
vous pouvez trouver cette question
étrange, et même déplacée.
Qui oserait penser
que les ingénieurs du CNES ou de la NASA
puissent donner leur feu vert
à des opérations aussi complexes,
voire aussi dangereuses,
en accordant la moindre place à ce que
nous appelons communément le hasard ?
Eh bien, je vais vous montrer
que le hasard existe bel et bien
dans l’aventure spatiale.
Et pour cela,
je vous inviterai à un voyage
dans l’espace et dans le temps.
Commençons par revenir en arrière,
à la jointure
entre les 16e et 17e siècles.
Jusqu’à cette époque, en Occident,
domine une représentation du réel,
qui peut être qualifiée
par un mot, celui de « Cosmos ».
Ce terme grec désigne la beauté.
Mesdames, pensez à vos cosmétiques
qui mettent en valeur
l’élégance de vos traits.
Eh bien, dans la bouche
ou sous la plume des philosophes,
ce terme désigne l’ordre, la mesure,
la perfection, l’éternité du ciel.
Qu’est-ce à dire ?
Eh bien, que la course des étoiles,
parfaite, immuable,
permet aux navires d’affronter les océans,
aux caravanes de traverser les déserts
et aux astrologues
de lever le voile sur l’avenir.
Du moins, dans cette conception cosmique
où tout est prévu,
tout est déterminé, tout est prédestiné,
et où le hasard,
le chaos, l’incertitude n’ont
absolument pas leur place.
Au centre du Cosmos se trouve la Terre.
Une exception.
Une verrue, pourrions-nous dire,
parce que nous le savons bien,
notre Terre n’est pas parfaite.
Notre planète est couverte de rides,
est ébranlée par des cataclysmes
en tous genres.
Les êtres qui la peuplent,
eux aussi sont loin d’être parfaits.
Ils sont mortels.
Ils sont tour à tour
les auteurs ou les victimes
de laideur, d’injustice, du mal.
Fort heureusement,
ils ne peuvent pas souiller le Cosmos.
Une frontière infranchissable a été placée
quelque part près de la Lune.
Ainsi, le ciel est interdit aux humains,
aux Terriens, aux terreux que nous sommes.
« Trop beau pour nous ! »
« Même pas en rêve ! »
Ces expressions sont peut-être triviales,
mais elles résument à merveille
la situation de nos prédécesseurs
devant le ciel.
Seuls les meilleurs d’entre nous,
les plus dématérialisés,
les plus spiritualisés,
peuvent espérer rejoindre un jour
la compagnie des êtres
qui peuplent le ciel.
Mais attention !
Après leur mort,
ou éventuellement durant
des expériences mystiques, extatiques,
surnaturelles, extra-terrestres,
je vous laisse le choix du terme.
Cette conception cosmique du monde
a un avantage.
Ordonné, déterminé,
le Cosmos offre une assurance globale,
une protection totale.
Rien ne peut arriver
par accident, par hasard.
Tout est réglé.
Tout est prévu, sauf - vous l’avez
deviné - le voyage dans l’espace.
Il faut donc une révolution.
Celle des astronomes au 17e siècle
pour ouvrir le ciel aux Terriens.
Après les spéculations
de Nicolas Copernic,
de Giordano Bruno,
Galilée et Johannes Kepler affirment
que le monde est constitué
d’une seule et même matière.
Qu'il est régi par les mêmes lois.
Autrement dit,
cette frontière posée entre le ciel
et la Terre n'a plus lieu d'être.
Le Cosmos est mort.
Vive l’Univers.
Dès lors,
le futur n’est plus sous la coupe
des dieux ou du destin,
il est entre les mains,
dans l’intelligence des humains,
qui vont chercher à connaître
les lois de l’Univers,
chercher à les maîtriser.
Et Descartes peut inviter
ses contemporains
à devenir comme maîtres
et possesseurs de la nature,
et Kepler peut prophétiser qu’un jour,
des humains suffisamment audacieux
oseront braver le ciel,
iront naviguer entre les étoiles,
et y inscrire eux-mêmes leur destin.
Désormais, le voyage dans l’espace
entre dans les rêves,
entre dans l’imaginaire des humains.
Pensez aux œuvres  de Cyrano de Bergerac,
à celles de Jules Verne,
ou encore de Georges Méliès.
Des rêves, des fictions,
qu’il ne reste plus qu’à réaliser.
Mais un obstacle se dresse
devant les Terriens.
Un obstacle, un écueil, un « rischio »,
disent les marins italiens.
Oui, un risque,
parce qu’avec la fin du Cosmos
et de l’assurance qui lui est associée,
les humains ne peuvent plus
invoquer les dieux ou le destin
pour expliquer
les dangers qu’ils rencontrent,
pour se disculper de leurs échecs.
Ils doivent prendre leurs responsabilités.
Ces explorateurs, ces marchands
qui affrontent les océans,
qui rejoignent le Nouveau Monde,
qui font le tour du monde,
ne peuvent plus se suffire
d’un « alea jacta est »,
« les dés sont jetés ».
Ils ne peuvent plus se confier au sort
des oracles et des augures,
ils doivent désormais mesurer, peser,
tergiverser avant de larguer les amarres.
Ils doivent chercher à connaître
les dangers, leur fréquence, leur coût.
Parce que les pertes, évidemment,
doivent rester inférieures aux gains.
Bref, le jeu, c’est-à-dire le risque,
doit en valoir la chandelle.
La conquête de l’espace
est tissée de la même étoffe.
Trois siècles et demi ont été nécessaires
pour doter, non plus d’ailes,
mais de navires,
les fils d’Icare, qui avaient décidé
d’échapper à ce labyrinthe
que construit la gravité autour d’eux.
Ce n’est évidemment pas par hasard
si l’une de leurs fusées s’appelle Ariane.
Il a fallu tout ce temps pour réaliser
ce qui paraissait impossible.
En particulier, naviguer dans le vide.
Il a fallu tout ce temps pour franchir
des seuils technologiques,
pour rassembler l’énergie
et les moyens nécessaires
pour construire ces monstres d’acier.
Il a fallu tout ce temps pour préparer,
entraîner des humains
à affronter le vide spatial.
Un milieu tellement risqué.
Évaluer le risque
couru par Youri Gagarine lorsqu’il est
devenu le premier humain dans l’espace,
évaluer le risque couru
par Neil Armstrong et Buzz Aldrin
lorsqu’ils ont marché sur la Lune,
évaluer ces risques reste
un exercice purement théorique,
parce que ces exploits sont hors normes.
A cette époque, eux-mêmes, leur nation,
avaient estimé
que le jeu en valait la chandelle.
Mais aujourd’hui,
en serait-il de même ?
Revenons sur terre,
et regardons vers le ciel.
Si c’est de nuit,
nous pourrons peut-être apercevoir
l’une des sentinelles que
nous y avons installées.
Ces satellites,
ces constellations de satellites,
nous offrent désormais
des services indispensables
lorsque nous voulons
communiquer entre nous,
nous informer, prévoir la météo,
nous localiser, nous déplacer.
Bien plus, ces armadas de satellites,
connectées aux systèmes informatiques,
aux intelligences artificielles,
nous donnent aujourd’hui
la toute-puissance, l’omniscience,
l’ubiquité,
qui jadis étaient prêtées aux dieux.
Alors, je me pose une question.
Je vous pose une question.
Est-ce que nous ne serions pas
en train de chercher à restaurer
l’ordre cosmique de jadis ?
Je veux dire par là, chercher à diriger,
à déterminer, à assurer nos existences,
l’existence de nos sociétés,
comme c’était le cas au temps du Cosmos.
L’espace semble pencher de ce côté.
Certes,
le risque n’a pas été réduit à zéro,
et il ne le sera jamais.
Mais en attendant que des missions amènent
à nouveau des humains autour de la Lune,
sur la Lune et un jour
peut-être jusqu’à Mars,
les projets actuels, en particulier ceux
entrepris par les barons de l’espace,
cherchent surtout à banaliser
l’accès à l’espace.
Oh, je sais bien !
Cette expression peut prêter
à question et à critique.
Il suffit de consulter le tarif
d'un simple vol suborbital.
Mais quelle offre touristique peut-elle
faire courir à ses clients
un risque aussi élevé que celui
de Gagarine, d’Armstrong ou Aldrin ?
Bien évidemment que le hasard
est persona non grata
à un comptoir d’agence de voyage,
même spatiale.
Dès lors, que sera l’espace demain,
en termes de risque et de hasard ?
Nul doute que la sécurité des vols
demeure le souci principal,
l’un des soucis principaux,
des ingénieurs, des agences,
des compagnies,
surtout lorsqu’ils proposent
des services commerciaux,
et en particulier touristiques.
Mais si l’exploration de l’espace reprend,
si de nouvelles frontières sont franchies,
des territoires inconnus sont explorés,
des humains vont se trouver confrontés
à des risques hors normes.
Alors se posera la question du but,
de la finalité,
de la raison d’être
de telles explorations.
Une destination
peut suffire à justifier
un voyage d’agrément,
dès lors que cette destination
est charmante ou exotique.
Mais aucune destination,
même la Lune, même Mars,
ne peut à elle seule justifier un voyage
où les risques sont équivalents à ceux
de Gagarine, Armstrong ou Aldrin.
Il faut de bonnes raisons pour chercher
à décrocher la Lune ou à décrocher Mars.
Dès lors, en prévision
de ces futures explorations
et des risques qui sont la condition même,
l’essence même
de ces activités, de ces rêves humains,
nous pouvons, nous devons,
dès aujourd’hui nous interroger.
Qu’avons-nous d’ores et déjà appris
grâce à l’aventure spatiale ?
Qu’allons-nous chercher
en allant dans les étoiles ?